three two four seven six seven eight
nine seven six four three seven six
lock
when i have plucked the rose
feel grey heart
long and still but that which stronger
nurses the deceit
in faith i do not love thee
shall i compare thee to a summer's day
when i have plucked the
rose longing still for that
subject for today
[Music]
oh
hello i didn't do the sip oh no i didn't
do the sip this morning oh
no what the hell am i doing with my nike
i'm not settling down for a long
winter's nap
i thought you were about to rob a
build-a-bear this is weird you guys can
see me though the lighting everything is
okay yeah yeah right there um never been
better i am running late today and the
reason that i'm running late is because
we have some exclusive uh info regarding
voter regularities and fraud in michigan
that um no one else has talked about
thus far
um that i know of
and i have been in touch with some
people some higher ups who have said
this is very interesting and something
that needs to be looked into and we've
also made some calls to county
commissions or election directors
whatever the term is uh so i'm going to
lay out this case for you much like i
did on election day uh regarding the
early voting remember in early voting
keep in mind i said i don't know why
people are saying that florida and ohio
are toss-ups yeah but they're not and i
said look at the early voting data i am
i'm entirely confident i'd be more
surprised
if ohio went blue than texas and i
remember ben shapiro was on the stream
when we crossed the streams with the
daily wire you know
with that never supposedly the old focus
stream very educated
[Laughter]
and they were talking about you know if
if trump wins oh i said ben what are you
talking ben of course he's going to win
ohio i have no doubt and i thought i was
taking crazy pills i said he's going to
win ohio by five to eight minimum and
he's going to win florida by a handful
of points certainly more than last time
i don't know why anyone is acting like
this is any different i would bet money
on it and those two were go back and
watch the election stream i was right i
feel the same way right now
because i felt like i was taking crazy
pills back then
and no one was paying attention to it
and i feel the same way right now and
i'll tell you why i think this is
uh it's because of course those on the
left will not cover what i'm about to
provide to you and you know there are
some people on the right not all but
there are some people who are grifters
who just free speech big tech okay what
else you got they're not going to put in
this work everyone here knows that it's
a i should look like christian bale from
the machinist i've been up all night
combing through and that's just wayne
county
one
county ladies and gentlemen so uh before
we move on to talk about that my half
asian lawyer bill richmond is here yo
and that is good to know today yeah i'm
here right uh dave landau is here of
course wonderful dave leonard from
compound media what you're talking about
thank you uh landau dave at landau dave
couldn't get dave landau
don't have the poll with old castaway no
not me
quarter black carrot is here
we do not have audio away because he had
faith surgery we're gonna check in with
him later poor guy uh i miss him i love
him and uh so we have tim from hr and
gerald a how are you sorry i'm well how
are you uh you know uh here's the thing
i'm actually i'm always happy i'm not
angry i'm in a good mood okay
a lot of people say why are you being
positive are you putting no i'm not
putting putting on appearances uh i'm a
christian conservative i live in the
united states of america for at least a
couple more months and
[Applause]
while it's still i think that's
something to be happy about there you go
yeah something what let me right away be
a downer before we move on to voter
fraud we're gonna continue with vote
fraud week please everyone watching
right now like this and share this yeah
i would not be surprised if this stream
gets taken down i would not be surprised
if this stream gets banned even though
everything i'm about to provide for you
comes from the wayne county
uh registration board their election
results officially yeah
when i run out of the room it's either
because we got banned and i've got to go
do some work or i really have to be yeah
so well ibs
it's that's you can't spend decades
eating dumplings it's just carbs bill or
dogs
[Laughter]
right away demonetized
he calls it the naughty language yeah
the racial stuff and dave you don't need
to be scared i can see a little scared
like this is extra this is news here
what's about to happen
this is gonna be fun i'm not used to
cereal
[Laughter]
you know he liked his white robe better
you know so yeah now we've got him in
this computer morally i like it better
oh by the way i need to i need to
i need to clip this gun thing because oh
there you go you know what happened was
uh i gave it to garrett's kids
oh they had a good time with it with the
gun i gave him out on halloween
would you give out a high point yes
kid's a good shot there by the way uh
quarterback okay so before i move on to
voter fraud there are a lot of stories
we have to get to right off the bat hate
to be a downer but it is the news and it
matters let's go to governor cuomo uh
where he was really pissy uh yesterday
may give stelter a run for his money
when asked about schools closing due to
covid this is a great interaction
when we did an orange zone in a red zone
in brooklyn and queens
and we closed the schools
don't you remember that
okay so don't you so what are you
talking about
how what are you talking about that
blurred sign it looks like little bird
because we can't see him yeah he did it
already
that's the law an orange zone in the red
zone
follow the facts i'm still confused well
then you're confused
parents are still confused as well
they're not confused
you're confused
read the law
read
i'll tell you why he's confused hold on
listen
this is great
the schools are open by state law
four hours later they were closed just
so you know
in the orange zone but in the red zone
and don't call me shirley
stop it stop that with the the blur
there i know
i just see him doing i hate how he sits
back like the godfather thing yeah yeah
yeah exactly you know he's at the head
of the table yeah like
right like if the godfather was just
pointing to a really small pecker come
on
come on come on try it you see like he's
like leaning back like look deep in my
nostrils and see that i'm right like
needlessly angry what happened to him
before that press conference runs in the
family i don't know he's never been to a
turkish prison
[Laughter]
uh hey by the way uh please do consider
as we get to some of more uh election
fraud uh details joining mug club
loudwithcrowder.com club we still have
the promo code crowder election stream
it's 30 off uh still because the
election is not over and as you will see
it's far from over
that you're you're not confused they're
confused there's a law i don't know why
my impression of cuomo is like a young
serpico al pacino
that's what he was like
send the cops to him now and then all of
a sudden he starts talking about big
asses
you're faking chill
when you see me run out it'll be too
late to have joined the blaze we will
already have been banned yes
and we'll be taking your live chat later
obviously exclusively on mug club and
nick depala will be on your good friend
there uh
from there uh uh uh dave london he's my
buddy and you don't need to read the
show map here just because i know i'll
be mirroring some info later just do
your do you yeah i'm trying to do man
you're brilliant all right well thank
you he does himself and then he sends me
the tape
uh now before we continue as well we
have to talk about uh master hirono no
you know what i'm talking about um audio
weight is not here because audio weighed
actually a long time ago he had a an
issue with his palette where it
basically caved in and they had to screw
it back and some screws fell loose and
if you guys saw we joked about his beast
face his face was really puffy he had a
face infection and they had to go in and
operate them so he's having a procedure
today so send him your love tweet him at
audio wade and uh we are actually though
i think he's coming out of the procedure
and um we can now actually check in
with the surgeon and an update how is
audio weight fairing
let us pray
in silence
one could drink let me tum straight
his face hurts
and where is his glasses he can't see
without his glasses
put his glasses on
put on his glasses
[Music]
oh
i really need to start providing
insurance for my employees that would
help yeah it would be nice i'm going to
put a bunch of books in his coffin just
he can take him to the other side yeah
why would macaulay culkin go piss off a
bee's nest if he's allergic i don't know
uh there's water nearby we're also going
to be uh watching the video recently
from cut about what what are white
people superior
when you have a title that ends with a
preposition
you know it's something we have to watch
and why do you think that there's a
tendency to criticize people for being
white male straight cis because that's a
thing now uh and do you think that's
going to increase under a biden
presidency are you what's your biggest
concern if biden were to become
president which
i don't know i think there's a kraken
coming out although it won't be defeated
as it was immediately in the original
literature okay so first let's go to
this hirono is it hirano hirono hirono
hirano she doesn't know so why should we
know
no
um
you know you know i don't know
all right
but i have taxpayer data so here she is
claiming just recently uh that
conservatives and this matters as we
head into a potential four-year biden
presidency i'll give you a 20 shot uh
that he does become president where she
actually spoke said these words that
conservatives do not face
any kind of censorship on social media
mr zuckerberg for the second time in
three weeks you've been called before
the senate committee so my republican
colleagues can
beat you up over claims that your
platforms are supposedly biased against
conservatives
the fact of the matter is that these
allegations are completely baseless
everyone who has systematically looked
at the content of social media from
media matters to the cato institute to
former republican senator john kyle has
found absolutely no evidence of
anti-conservative bias
well listen i don't know about media
matters
uh but i will say there have been some
people who've been specifically calling
for censorship and criticism of
conservatives solely for their point of
view not everybody uh
but you miss hirono
youtube dragged his feet before taking
any action against conservative
commentator stephen crowder
when youtube did finally take action it
took the half measure of removing
advertisements from crowder's videos
rather than removing him from the
platform entirely okay first thing that
is a flat face when she turns down you
cannot see eyes or a nose yes it's a
safety feature
oh i was if i was
a safer person i wish i had gotten that
from my mom where did we talk about
where did the term slope come from
that's that's a bluff dude i have no
idea man i strongly prefer charlie
i feel like okay i'm gonna win a golden
ticket
calm down charlie it's usually just a
burnt down village though
it is but that's only southeast asia oh
right yeah in china we do the burning
geography
here's why also hirono the reason she
was complaining that we were demonetized
and not banned
facts should matter i i know that you
know this uh being a frequent visitor of
media matters um
it's because the ceo of youtube the most
powerful media company in existence said
clearly that we did not that i had not
violated any policies my half asian
lawyer bill richmond true untrue yeah
that's true fact check so hirono wants
these companies to ban according to her
own words shows like this rather than be
demonetized because we're conservative
so it it's literally
the most clear thing i know hey there's
no there is no bias but bang him right
she's saying they said there's no
violation they took a half measure the
full measure would have been silence
this entire channel all all the hundreds
of videos never again to be seen on
youtube but uh you know we'll just go
ahead and leave everything else up and
you know what we've been remonetized so
really it's a few quarters
is she the sexy young girl that said
that the word sexual preference is in
fact hateful
uh yes she is the one and then uh miriam
webster changed the definition of sexual
preference being hateful real fast by
the way she used it not long ago and
current sitting senators used it like
last week yeah that's what i assume
i never knew it was hateful it doesn't
mean that it's not not an immutable
quality as they say sexual preference
for example if someone says oh steven's
sexual preference is a woman sure
steven's sexual preference is a tall
blonde cool glasses of water like my
wife yeah that's true not offended
doesn't mean that because your sexual
preference is hairy man ass that you
weren't born that
way you are making a moral judgment you
were born with an orientation that
oriented you toward hairy sweaty man ass
and it is also your preference i'm right
here you're from strokes
why are you talking about gerald's wife
again
whoa
she says she thinks you're attractive
gerald what what's wrong i'm going to
kill him she's saying that her
preference is your hairy ass that's what
you're denying you call your wife
no oh shut up general joe they just said
your wife loves you whatever my gosh man
you know what
it's his problem because he doesn't
think he's worthy of love you are oh you
are worthy of love gerald you might
check that you're right also silence
uh here's something else biden's
transition team one of his team members
richard stengel uh he wrote an op-ed
explaining why the u.s needs a hate
speech law like europe where by the way
people can be arrested for doing a cover
of kung fu fighting or our good friend
mike ward in canada where their speech
laws put for human rights tribunal for
making a joke so this is an active
member a current member of biden's
transition team saying we need a hate
speech law combine that with hirono
saying ban stephen crowder even though
it's clear on the record legally that he
didn't violate any policies as well as
the little minor detail that there are
former facebook higher-ups involved with
biden's transition team and you actually
have a you have a stage five shitty cane
it's a double-barreled [ __ ] machine gun
with a hair trigger
thank you officer leahy
she
people need to go back and look at just
like the hate speech thing remember when
we went down in front of google's uh sub
regional headquarters in austin downtown
austin and we talked about how many how
many different people who came up from
hipster leftist austin and were like i
think hate speech should be a real thing
and every single one of them to a t said
yeah i guess yeah i guess you're right
right and by you know what's really
telling donald trump this crazy evil
fascist who's been president for four
years and brought you the best economy
we've had in modern american history and
brought back american manufacturing jobs
guess what he had this power you said
that he wielded it like a fascist didn't
you didn't do everything by executive
order unlike barack obama unlike you're
going to see with job and they still all
use more executive orders than i would
be comfortable with but guess what he
never once
tried to limit speech of liberals
he said that the press the press is
dishonest fake news he talked about that
he wanted balance in fact what do we
call for we say well hey hold on a
second if we're gonna have southern
poverty law center and ap who lied about
the trump team legal case or snopes who
lied about many of our stories at
loudouartscrider.com where all the
sources will be available today all we
want is to have some right what some
right leaning balance to it donald trump
the fascist dictator hitler in chief
apparently never once stood before a
committee never once stood before a
governing body and said get rid of
hirono because she's got a weird flat
face and she's a [ __ ] he never once
said that we fought for your right to be
there because we want everyone to see
how stupid your arguments are yeah if we
had complete and total we had the senate
right with the senate with the
presidency the executive office and we
have the supreme court
no conservatives have been pushing for
laws to silence you hirono only you you
are pushing for people to act outside of
their legal purview to ban folks like
this show because we say things that you
don't like despite it not being a
violation of policy and you know what
else you know what else really gets my
goat in forever a muslim is
oh you have a sexual nature no senator
hirono have you ever
seen or entered into a settlement
related to this kind of conduct
no senator
and if i greeted you on airplane and
handed you scarf would you feel welcome
yes
if i touched your knee real throw like
this what do you think you like that
you think she asks those questions of
everyone she hires yeah right do you
think she asked that the question of the
president that she voted for you think
she has a matlab power button in her
office
i think she's more a louis c.k yeah yeah
that's true just blocks the door hey
come on into green room yeah i hear
you're right to watch
so is that raw duck oh my gosh hirono
rub the magic ranter in the green room
it's uh time this is something i
stumbled across please everyone share
this right now at this second this is
what might get this stream banned we're
about to get into it specifically
exclusive no one else has done this yet
it's time to continue fraud week
[Music]
okay so you can go to crowder bits and
see the catalog we did dominion we did
georgia we did nevada and pennsylvania
and we wanted to end on michigan and
that's because uh mr dave landau and
myself uh are our michiganders that's
right and you currently live in detroit
right uh yeah well i live in new york
and uh detroit yes don't you live in
gross point though that's right i love
our docs dave yeah i'm sorry no you're
fine we published his address in the
show notes so i'm sure it's out there i
uh yeah no i grew up uh in the wayne
county area the good thing is he doesn't
need security he just surrounds his one
house with a bunch of bombed out crack
houses so they act as a natural force
field and pit bulls that aren't mines
some call it
roaming animals of death and others call
them a natural force someone breached
the perimeter here with lucky what do we
do with them throw them on electric
fence what the hell do i
care it's
they don't like me either but i just
know where they are you just throw them
on the fence like uh like a doctor grant
testing this fence and with a stick well
how do you dress up know if it works
that's a good point and we know that the
guard dog doesn't he's surprisingly
quiet today because i know i told him
there's a topic later yeah dave i know
they have some third rails i'm sorry i'm
not being quiet no
i love you i'm just and i love you i
just i don't know what we're going to
get into well and i will say dave landau
follow him he's one of the funniest
human beings on the planet and so is
nick depalo but dave landau is nice
that is the difference so wayne county
for people who don't know wayne county
is detroit and wayne county encompasses
many other uh i guess county but
municipality cities that are in that
county it's a pretty big county and
people been talking about michigan
considering that michigan was one i
believe by a margin of 140 something
thousand votes at 4 a.m
well that's what we're about to get into
so i was going through the voting
records because i know michigan and i
didn't even have time to get to kent
county and the deeply red counties in
the western side of the state as many
people know because some margins there
don't make a whole lot of sense
unfortunately not all of that data is
available but i am working with from the
official wayne county election
commission website right here
these numbers and i asked everyone last
night i asked you last night half vision
bill i said uh are you noticing anything
when i sent you the document was like a
hundred and something pages and i didn't
realize that i'm the only one me and reg
who read like 150 page documents
i mean i regularly read millions of
pages for cases but then no i'm not
little no no no no no but the point was
there's a the moms have been so into
this she is watching and she's like did
you read more pages than stephen
vaccine 95.56
she was she's very upset that it's not
97. yeah so but when you when you looked
at it and then later you pointed out i
was like wow you only would know this if
you'd been living it like living right
analysis the entire time so yes okay so
let's bring this up here here's a
statement of the votes report from wayne
wayne county so i have this i'm
mirroring my screen uh forgive me if
this is a little bit raw
because i have to zoom in and i'm using
an ipad but look let's start with this
you see the city of detroit right city
of detroit the precinct so what do we
have here keep in mind you have
registered voters at the top there here
i'll show you registered voters at the
top then you have cards cast voters cast
and percent of turnout so percent of
turnout is based on registered voters
right that's important very knowing the
registered voters and the percentage of
turnout that's how you estimate it so we
look in these detroit precincts and
these are pretty small like 752 uh here
you have over a thousand here you have
801. some of these only have 69 but if
you look at the turnout rate it's very
low
right you have 15 percent there uh maybe
14 here 14 here 15 12
you have some that are as low as 10
percent the highest i've seen here is 20
percent so this is all detroit precincts
okay i want to follow along here 16 24
17 25 17 here let's keep scrolling
because it goes on for detroit precincts
for a while 14
13 13
21 is pretty high there 16 14 12 okay
these numbers are pretty consistent
across the board 11 where if you look at
all these detroit precincts uh the voter
turnout is uh
between 10 and 20 there are a few
they're a little bit higher but it's
between 10 and 20 the voter turnout
right based on registered voters and
these detroit precincts okay so that's
pretty low um and you notice here by the
way the av meaning uh um we're talking
about the absentee ballots that uh some
of these weren't counted so these are
the in day election turnouts just to be
clear right i want to be clear about
this because now i'm going to go through
the surrounding not counties but
municipalities in detroit because we
know detroit would be where it's most
liberal wayne county a lot of people
don't realize wayne county encompasses a
lot of places like gross point yeah like
livonia canton some very suburban
working class sometimes upper white
middle class you have areas outside of
detroit that are 95 percent white taylor
i think too taylor as well northville
township
[Laughter]
so let me do this really quickly here i
will search in for example uh gross
point okay because now we'll move down
the document
sorry gross
okay it's with an e there we go yeah no
a little more pretentious okay so now we
go to gross point we look oh wow
we still have registered voters as you
see there and we have the turnout rate
and we have total turnaround 84
84 82 82 82 75 is the lowest we see
there 83 even if you look at the in day
voting percentage they're all between 25
mostly between 25 and 30 percent some of
them are absentee ballots but you see a
higher voting percentage by quite a
significant margin right 80 percent here
73. uh now look let me do this i'm going
to continue scrolling through here so
because these are all part of wayne
county and then something's going to
surprise you because we thought we were
done with detroit right right
all right let's go down to
livonia very white
livonia we have 79 80 84 turnout rate 85
turn rate these are crazy turnout rates
by the way that surprised me in and of
itself so detroit we only have of the
precinct 17 average between 10 and 20
percent
and now in all the surrounding suburban
areas hard hard trump country livonia
gross point i can bring up canton again
this is all available at
lighterworthcrater.com we will make
these sources available to
you you see a voter turnout rate of 80
85 75
which should tell you that that is a an
absolute blowout for donald trump
because these are hard hard trump areas
well and livonia's so white was trending
not long ago yes it was
so white
yeah everybody's property that's where i
think they poured some clorox on jesse
smallett's personal trainer they did
yeah but it didn't work
if the only piece of data that you have
is this and you're a campaign manager
for donald trump you're popping
champagne right you're popping champagne
and by the way these are big these are
much bigger than the detroit precincts
right you saw some 60 people you saw
some that were 700 people the highest
that you saw up there or maybe a
thousand something not many precincts in
the thousands but these have many
thousands of respon of uh of uh
registered voters and a high percentage
of voter turnout so melvindale i would
imagine is white i don't know northfield
very white 83 84 percent you can keep on
going down here plymouth is very white
they have a great haunted house erebus
85 so these numbers are consistent no
that's pontiac oh that's pontiac that's
a little hoity-toity oh is it that's
right so either way plymouth is uh not
not exactly mixed now i say this because
this is also important donald trump did
more right with minority voters than any
other republican in modern history he
did better than he did in 2016. so
that's important to keep in mind that
even with these precincts in detroit
that might have 15 total voter turnout
that we saw a higher percentage of
blacks latinos and women's would have
come out for donald trump because that
happened in every other county
okay but now we look at the area where
we expected donald trump to win and we
have 80 something percent voter turnout
in much bigger account in much bigger
municipalities all in wayne county but
this is what was weird so i did this and
then all of a sudden van buren i'm
pretty sure that's uh pretty sure that's
uh that's a caucasian area okay so it's
pretty much a a garbage dump is it
really a garbage dump actual garbage
like a ski a slope as well
that's like in i think in lewisville
texas i have a friend who lives there
i'm like oh you guys have a you guys
have a sledding hill he's like no that's
uh that's landfill that's our trash
though plymouth actually had soccer moms
uh defund the police rally
in the town center right by like the
tiny theater and gazebos and stuff it
was quite hilarious because they needed
the police to watch them and it was all
white soccer moms and lululemon
what am i gonna what am i gonna do have
have the lady in the fabletics monitor
she can't throw a punch
my my dog's therapist would be pretty
good at this job okay so just to be
clear what i just so we are right now at
this point we are left with detroit yeah
yeah
15 turnout rate average yeah and then
all the surrounding areas that are hard
hard trump country many thousands of
registered voters that we see there 80
percent average turning up to vote we
know that that's obviously heavily trump
but then we get to the bottom here and
all of a sudden detroit comes back
but do you notice something
zero registered voters
n a
as far as percent of vote turnout zero
registered voters and by the way these
are much bigger than the precincts
before 2500 votes 1900 votes 2100 votes
some of these are up to like three
thousand votes thirty thirty four
hundred votes thirty three hundred votes
twenty one hundred votes twenty three
hundred votes twenty nine hundred votes
with zero registered voters and the
percent of voter turnout
this by the way these numbers here that
have zero registered voters no data
whatsoever that you could match against
let's say if you were doing some kind of
canvassing if you were doing some kind
of actual recount there'd be no way to
actually check because there are zero
registered voters in the books this
totals up to around 173
000 voters again look zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero now i know
what some people are going to say well
that's the ace avcb which is the
absentee voters counting ballot what's
uh
committing uh counting bureau i forgot
the uh what the actual acronym is for
here but um
let me let me bring this up to the
accounting board
bureau so they would say okay hold on a
second so this is their argument
is well that's from the absentee ballots
okay
we've called we've made two calls to
county boards and to people who were
handling these elections we were not
able to get through to anybody it still
doesn't give you any reason as to why
they wouldn't have registered voters at
all let's assume for a second that all
these votes came in really quickly like
drinking from a fire hose well it
doesn't matter you still have long
before election registered voters that's
how they do the polls right the liberal
polls were doing registered voters
instead of doing likely voters so that
doesn't change the fact that that data
shouldn't read zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero
and this totals 173 000 votes
from zero registered voters in those
precincts so what are we left with we're
left with the detroit precincts where we
have some data on registered voters okay
we know the registered voters and a 15
turnout rate average then we have heavy
heavy heavy trump country growth point
places like livonia places like canton
right places where you would have
working middle class some union guys but
people who whisked trump into the white
house last election with an 83 percent
average voting turning vote voter
turnout rate so detroit we have numbers
for some reason 15 voting rate the other
areas where it would be white working
working class blue collar trump voters
85 percent voter turnout rate then zero
in all of these absentee ballots zero
registered voters which give us 173
000 votes from 134 uh abcbs
now keep in mind
that late on election night in the
middle of the night there was a ballot
dump
with about
000 ballots yeah all for biden yeah less
than four percent about three percent
took place for donald
were actually cast for donald trump that
doesn't occur anywhere in nature you
could have an election in america's
communist party and donald trump would
get more than three percent of the vote
so this area where there's no way to
actually check these votes at all no
registered voters
and we have a dump i want to make sure i
get this number right 150 000 votes on
election night less than 6 000 for trump
that's about three percent of the votes
and you want to say there are no
irregularities there's no reason to
count this well those are just absentees
so they're from acvb so whoa hold on a
second
why don't you have registered voters
furthermore do you know what the average
turnout rate would have to be for these
absentee ballots
a hundred percent wow it would have to
be a hundred percent for these remaining
votes and they would all have to go to
biden
assuming it would have to be more than a
hundred percent because if there's one
vote that comes in that's higher than
that's already 200 percent because it's
zero
there are no registered voters and it
all tipped all the data that we do have
available for us which by the way you
should have in elections and most
counties do this is just a rule of wayne
county right yeah yeah if you have more
than 250 precincts then the other ones
can just be a a they can just be acvb's
whatever it's called absentee ballot
counting and at that point you can just
count them as much as you want take them
as they come in but why don't you have
registered voters and how can we
understand the voter turnout rate we
have three turnout rates right now okay
we have detroit registered voters about
15 turnout rate we have everywhere else
in wayne county deeply red we have an
odor over 80 percent turnout rate and
then we have a third turnout rate which
is n a because 150 000 votes came in in
the middle of night from zero registered
voters 100 percent of which 97 percent
it's a rounding error for donald trump
keep in mind by the way remember that
138
128 000 votes that happened in wisconsin
that ended up being a typo yeah yeah
that's less
that's less yeah yeah than the ballot
dump that actually took place in
michigan in the middle of night with 97
coming in for biden and zero registered
voters for 173 000 of those votes the
lead in michigan by the way for biden is
146 000. something else that's a huge
chunk of detroit because detroit has to
be a big city the last census tried to
claim there were 700 thousand people in
detroit and we all laugh it's an ongoing
joke
it's not it's like 250 000 and one
crackhead just filed for unemployment if
you count the put pit bulls around
dave's house right yeah and a lot of
them wear
and one other thing that's important
because well this is how they do their
elections it's not how they did it in
the primaries is this zero
i'm sorry i just uh you should be
140 000 people
of zero people 173 000 votes
from zero registered voters according to
the record make sure i heard that right
yeah yeah yeah so okay so what they've
done is they've broke at the very best
they've broken this out into a way that
you cannot figure out exactly how many
people voted in each one of these
precincts and they didn't do it anywhere
else in the county right they didn't do
it anywhere else anywhere else why do we
have records from areas in detroit
county that are smaller precincts a
dozen here a few hundred there maybe
every now and then you throw in a
precinct with a thousand but the big
ones four thousand three thousand zero
registered voters
no information so
this isn't this isn't an election
irregularity
this is what you would do if you were
trying to commit fraud
and this is what we suspected right when
we said hold on a second we went to
sleep and there was this ballot dump how
does that happen and how did the state
flip because before we went to bed we
were effectively calling the presidency
for donald trump well these came no one
expected 140 something thousand ballots
coming in 97 for biden we said well
we're gonna have to look into those
numbers that seems weird now you can't
because there are zero registered voters
we have no idea as to the voter turnout
the turnout could be
130 percent it would have to be that
yeah for this to actually make sense at
best this is by design
a way to cover up voter fraud and again
it's not how they did it in the
primaries so even in the democratic
primary so when they when they wanted to
get their candidate right they made sure
that they didn't have this kind of a
lack of data at so really at worst this
is designed to commit fraud and have no
way to be fact checked at best we have
to believe that a these people are
totally unaccountable that no one cares
no one in the media has actually done
this research and looked at these
numbers and that uh they uh they just uh
they're like well you know what uh we
don't have russian voters so um ah
just do it just don't worry about it
guys it'll be fine
unless you think more data is coming
that will clear all of this up uh isn't
there a news story about some county
rushing to certify the election results
yes we are going to get to that we are
going to get to that in a second
relevant but this is really important
for people to understand
that
that there's no way to know when there
are zero registered voters and there's
no reason to not have a tally of
registered voters i understand let's say
it takes a while to count like arizona's
still counting i don't know how many
coffee breaks they take a lot a lot a
little bit
we've heard we've heard about the
demographic changes in arizona siestas
we get it you haven't finished the
counting
but that's the ballots where you say
well we don't actually we don't have the
number that we still have to go through
the ballots fine that doesn't change the
fact that you have the registered voters
long before election that's not
something that happens on election night
what you do on election night is match
your ballots with the registered voters
there's no reason for that to be a zero
there is no reasonable explanation for
that to be a zero and we've called twice
and we've been given the runaround and
no one has given an answer uh at all and
again this is not the way that they did
this in the primaries we're going to
continue with michigan election fraud
but this is something that did you have
a question i think you were no i was
just going to play a little devil's
advocacy if you you know take out kwame
kilpatrick that was the mayor of detroit
being in prison and dennis archer
weirdly running out before stuff got out
and culminated young's entire you know
yeah white boy rick
miles yeah the democratic party i think
has done a pretty good job
it's all about perspective they wanted
to lower the population when you
eliminate detroit they've done a good
job with detroit exactly
sure we had a riot and then it was no
more detroit's like lindsay lohan like
you you watch them in the news and
people like detroit's coming back
you watch them and and you feel you feel
for and you really hope that they get it
right
but you know they're never going to yeah
it's just going to be another crack
bender and at some point a burka for
some reason that then disappears and is
replaced with that uh bracelet whatever
that was that burke is called dearborn
yes
by the way had a crazy turnout rate too
out of nowhere yeah the illan omar area
who knew uh but before we continue now
with some of the election data that is
publicly available that you may not know
um our correspondent uh thomas finnegan
is uh here with us today for fraud facts
oh i don't know if we had an intro for
thomas finnegan no
do we not quite a black yard all right
thomas finnegan is here thomas i thought
we were going to you you're here i
thought you were on location no i i'm
here today all right well yeah we can't
really hear you okay so thomas finnegan
it's fraud week
uh
you have some problems apologize first
for
uh chopping the ball earlier earlier
this week yeah i'm sorry what's the well
he with the frog facts it's fraud
some facts about frauds you have some
facts fraud facts good relevant thank
you for doing the research uh it was a
film that came out in australia in 1993
with phil collins and hugo weaving
the the soundtrack is not available for
purchase
and
it was in competition in 1993 for
ken's film festival award
okay well first we're doing we're that
that doesn't even seem like fraud that
just seems like a tidbit that's like a
did you know if frauds um
uh this is yeah this is more about uh
fraudulent elections
oh if you want to talk about numbers
okay yeah it grossed about 30 000
australians yeah no that's not relevant
we were talking about fraud fraudulent
elections election fraud
all right you know what we have a
sponsor here gabby how about you read
that for us thomas let's earn your pay
here
i know i know that your wife still you
still have formula to buy
give us some water yeah you can have
some water
yeah okay well you know what uh all
right angela let's get some more water
in here you can probably keep it okay
gabby our wonderful sponsor gabby as we
continue with michigan fraud facts go
ahead thomas finnegan you know you're
probably overpaying on car and home
insurance sure you'd love to save money
but spending hours on your own
shopping for low rates
to maybe save a few bucks is probably
not
thomas finnegan everybody thank you very
much i'll take it from here okay so uh
gabby is a wonderful sponsor we're
really happy about them it's actually a
lot of people here um are using
insurance i'll be back uh with some
fro frog facts no you we don't know
fraud week is over leave leave thomas
finnegan thank you thomas finnegan
everybody so uh a lot of you pay for
insurance uh at home and you don't
realize insurance is one of those things
you get locked into and then your rates
just keep rising and rising and you
could actually be saving a lot of money
so we entered this in and we're wildly
surprised uh with things like car
insurance or different kinds of
insurance so if you go to gabby it's uh
gabby.com crowder you'll get a free
quote just punch in your insurance
information and they'll show you what
you could be paying elsewhere it's one
of those things that's basically free
money on the table you might be
overpaying a lot of people are i gotta
say i was surprised i gotta tell you use
use the money you save by going to gabby
and uh join mug club yeah
it's free right
or we'll start a gofundme for thomas
finnegan to go he needs it he wants to
go independent let's put him in a broken
down helicopter and send him a flight
all right that's a king speech not so
good but you know so i also had a great
experience with gabby and also since
they don't sell your data it's another
little fu to big tech which i appreciate
so right um i really don't think you
should drink out of
much angela bring in some uh other water
drink out that
if you can if you don't mind someone can
bring it in so let's continue on with
michigan what was it that you brought up
well no in the michigan thing i i don't
understand what the logic would be other
than fraud right so you're trying to
think in the in the world of what
they're doing why would you separate it
out when you don't do it anymore that's
not what you brought up you brought up a
point about uh about people uh uh
certifying the election sorry oh yeah
yeah yeah that is something we need to
get into but before we continue with the
rest of michigan fraud it is important
because i know a lot of you saw this we
covered it while it was happening live
we had the exclusive but to set the tone
there is a question mark
behind why did they do this at the
precinct covering it up uh for a lack of
accountability in detroit proper and
wayne county this happened
look at the knot of approval
yeah they do that when i walk by
preschools yes
[Laughter]
i do that on the side of my van when i
drive by preschool yes
you know i can't afford i can't afford
siding who buys this all glass van
i don't know
but the bristol boards come in handy
and make a trip to staples
timmy's none the wiser it's almost like
they should be able to see through those
windows it's also easier to write on
like puppies yeah oh yeah you know free
candy inside yeah because one day it's
ice cream and you're like how i get i
don't want to go buy a puppy van right
no exactly marker it's a multi it's like
it's a modular
rapist fan yes
that's what i'm saying
and by the way it's for someone else not
for you yeah
uh okay so the michigan uh board of
canvassers this is what you were talking
about they refused to certify wayne
county okay after they said that
absentee ballot poll books at 70 of
detroit's 134 absentee counting boards
were found to be out of balance without
explanation
here's the thing i'm assuming that some
of that comes from what we just showed
you and i think a lot of this is lost in
translation because everyone talks about
election fraud and they want the sound
bite they want the tidbit and they go oh
some things are out of balance but they
don't know exactly why
is it just me or was that shocking to
you to see zero zero zero zero zero it's
incredibly shocking not only because
when you think about how they did in the
primaries which is very you when we look
at these things we say okay this is how
it is but how does it compare to what it
should be under the rules the
regulations the guidelines and also how
have you done it in the past right and
when you see something that is wildly
out of whack just a completely different
system with completely different results
you have to ask the question why right
and when the results all tend to go in
exactly one direction like 97
right it's 97 it's a pretty high it's a
pretty high 90's which is more than the
voting win number it's a lot it's a lot
and then you look at that and you know
entirely if it were entirely black
lesbian women donald trump would get
more than three percent yeah
people understand that if it were phd
afro-lesbian funk studies majors ooh
funk hmm
they would still give donald trump more
than three percent antifa would vote
more than three percent for donald trump
we go well this is weird and how can we
uh factor it well it's a zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero so when you read
this from the canvassers right the
people who refuse to certify it it just
says oh seventy percent of the absentee
voting priests were out of balance
people go well that seems suspicious
someone should look into it we just did
unfortunately a lot in conservative
media don't give you more than the sound
bite we just did now you know it's
incredibly disturbing go to the website
little cutter.com read it for yourself
give me an easy explanation here i'm
looking to be wrong i could be wrong
there could be a really easy fix i don't
know what it is and we've reached out to
the officials in charge and they don't
answer they don't seem to know what it
is here's the thing these people refused
to certify it was a deadlock two to two
then
they were doxxed and all of a sudden
they said we'll certify
so
yeah what they actually said was
bound to be out of balance and these are
the quotes without explanation just
think about how bad of an admission that
is well i mean it's not bad they were
being honest they said without
explanation right and that's why they
didn't want to certify it's not and we
had some explanations that needed to be
borne out with some more explanation or
some detail or we have some theories
that seem plausible that make sense we
need to get some more data right it was
just literally guys like in our wildest
imaginations we cannot come up with an
explanation for these numbers so we
should pump the brakes and then the
entire leftist world goes no brake pump
vegas right cut the line drop off the
brakes
listen all i'm saying is we should
investigate these
173 uh thousand plus votes that came in
in the middle of the night all for joe
biden well uh why do you say that
because that number is higher than the
total of registered voters which was
zero
right i feel like they buried the leader
a little bit they were like oh you know
this is a irregular it's out of balance
if you had come out and said there are
173 000 votes that we can't account for
and we need to make sure we can i think
that would have been a stronger argument
to the public then they're out of
balance well that balance would be five
votes but here's the thing is they
didn't even want to get to that point
they were doing their job and said we
can't certify this we need to go in so
here's what happened they said we can't
certify it they were doxed and so then
the news was like oh now they certified
it but actually they said uh they were
sending their votes by the way these
people they said they were bullied into
certifying the election you know i i
think we're getting a little loose with
the terminology bullying if someone
lists your name birth date address
personal hobbies and schedule yeah it's
not like you were getting a swirly yeah
ask you to hold a ticking package for
them
giving that lady a wedgie there was just
someone outside of their house one of
those professional sign spinners
but you know what i'm very confident is
is that was a lot of people who preached
love
and unity yeah were the ones that were
saying certified
or we'll eat your children yeah well you
know what though you can love someone
and hurt them like my dad's spanking me
they're basically uh loading up their
357 magnum saying this is going to hurt
me much more than it's going to hurt you
tough love i don't know about that
canvassing board we're making a list
checking in twice
um bipartisan board by the way yeah
bipartisan bipartisan board and you
don't think they realized what they were
doing if they were going guys we're
looking at this information it is going
to cause a storm if we don't certify
these results but
we are compelled keep talking i'm going
to go shut off this monitor because i
see dave oh no he's looking at it
ethically
morally
[Laughter]
i wouldn't wear underwear what is this
look at this these are more pajamas look
these look at this stop look at this
look at this
my mother-in-law bought these for me for
skiing and she goes hey why don't you
try mine show me how you like it i
walked out felt a breeze and my
mother-in-law i'm sorry you had to see
my dick that's why she's on her
she's like steven go try these on yeah i
just i felt the breeze i was like
i didn't want to look down because i was
hoping for the best going hmm
but that wouldn't be my big fat dick
swinging out there no one would design a
fly that way would they why would they
do that to me she sent me a scenario no
it's not that big now
[Laughter]
it's out there but it was swinging but
it was inside i can't get out that's why
the annulment was in play
okay uh so here's another one michigan
let's go through some other what are you
going to say i'm going to look at you no
you don't need to look i just i
know what happens is when people have
information on the screen they look at
it it's like you guys don't need to know
that stuff because it's my job you're
just you're you you're funny i'm just
by the numbers isn't it crazy i just
feel the like i'm surprised this is
politicians cheating and not the little
rascals
the numbers are insane it's just the
mayor of detroit coming in in a trench
coat on somebody else's shoulders right
well all these absentee ballots
[Applause]
now remember remember the story that
that you covered the day after the
election about the lack of security at
this at bristol board university right
which is the what is it they call it
cold hall or cobo hall
now it's like tcf right right but yeah
at this very location right so so this
isn't you know oh we're bringing in this
issue in this state and this issue in
this county it's all the same place all
in the same place it's zero registered
voters with 173 000 votes yeah in the
same building right that we showed you
had no security during the hours and we
showed people
we weren't counting we showed people
going in with wagons and coolers because
it was happening live like it just
happened and then people said oh is
camera equipment in your conspiracy no
no we weren't talking about it for sure
being ballots in those coolers we were
saying why is someone able to go in with
a full cooler with no security into a
voting precinct i got stopped through
tsa because i had a bottle of shampoo
that was 4.2 ounces right just to be
clear they're going in to to basically
be in charge of the state of western
civilization and they're just bringing
in real red wagons well you know what
their response was the response was i
can't do my work look at all of these
coolers and suitcases and wagons and
look one of the wagons might have just
been camera equipment and you're like oh
okay okay great
awesome able to show us that this wasn't
this wasn't fraud and that the issues
there and the wagon the wagon was
innocent yeah okay so let's continue the
investigation nope investigation over
hold on let me see that cooler open it
up it's empty why what's in there
registered voters the prestige
hey listen the local fox 2 news woman
has spoken right yes that's all it was
she came out she's like guys come on i i
have a question
all right did nikon partner with yeti
and now you have like cooler solidus
radio flyer got together with that gun
and said yeah what's the vote yeah uh i
do not know but i would love to tell you
about the new rei improved scandium
carabiners that you can purchase now for
20 off don't got to wait till black
friday
we got a black day every day at rei
that's like the worst excuse ever it's
camera equipment yes because people
carry camera equipment in igloo coolers
unless they're a republican in which
case they're not allowed to use their
campaigns yeah and radio they just fly
your wagons yeah
like they're then you have to stand
before them a republican poll watcher
goes in with a camera and they smash it
like bluetooth
with a guitar okay here's some other
facts here uh michigan they already had
problems with the mail in ballots
earlier in the august 4 primary 6400
absentee ballots had to be thrown out
including by the way 846 ballots from
dead voters now i know every now and
then you'll get a story from bbc or
huffpole they'll say meet the michigan
dead voter who's speaking out and she's
like i'm not dead yet and goes well
that's good enough for me listen there
can be some mix-ups but again in august
846 ballots from dead voters had to be
thrown out that's just 846 out of 6 400.
wow now combine that with the fact that
mail-in ballots in the general election
were accepted at 30 times the rate of
any other previous election and the fact
that we have 173 000 votes in detroit
proper from zero registered voters
i don't know at what point we can use
the word [ __ ] but i think we're about
there here's some more information 47
mission counties of course by the way
they use dominion software
so uh i don't know
all of the counties that use michigan
suffer but maybe that could explain some
other glitches that have taken place in
michigan so we can tally this up
primaries thousands of votes have had to
be dismissed including 800 from dead
people zero registered voters with 173
000 votes that came in 97 for biden poll
watchers not being allowed as they add
up bristol boards but now we have a
glitch of course in michigan that we
know about in antrim county uh where 6
000 votes flipped from biden to trump
now here's what they're saying well we
caught it before the election well yeah
you probably caught it before the
election because you were able to match
it against registered voters because it
wasn't zero
[Music]
then there was another glitch in oakland
county and i don't know if they used
dominion uh and it led uh officials to
declare they declared a democrat a
winner right yeah the republican
conceded oops and then they called him
said hey yeah about that you didn't need
to do that
he said what he said you won he's like
oh man that must have been close he won
but like a thousand votes and it's a
small county he's like you're
bullshitting i won by a thousand votes
but i conceded last night we don't know
what happened it was a glitch so did he
retract his concession do you concede
concede yeah i don't know i maybe he'd
just like tweet or they were like
officials
yeah and his opponent said no take that
like double quickies no races yeah right
they like moved in and they were like
doors locked doors locked what was that
dave i said it's called indian giving
yes oh wow no
you take it back it's ready we know what
it is gerald
it's red skin filled red
there you go
sometimes if people are undoubtedly um
yes
so now we have this those are two
counties in michigan so we caught it and
by the way there's always a fall person
you know that we talked about in georgia
oh two
memory cards were found someone just
misplaced the memory card in michigan it
was someone didn't update the software i
don't really even know what their
excuses here in uh in oakland county and
we've heard
several different excuses just listen
just get over it the democrat one now
the republican one we're like oh okay
well well it seems like there might be
some errors can we go check out those
173 000 votes from zero registered
voters no you don't want anything about
that gonna waste your time buddy let's
just go on and give back in the election
so they're excuses a van dropped them
off but it's camera equipment you're
like wait no i don't know if you heard
me yeah
i'm wondering how all those votes got
here and you're like yeah yeah it's a
red wagon i think we're missing each
other
oh you're a racist but don't worry we
were able to see when the wagon was
pulled in and they brought it into the
room but then somehow the windows got
very
unseeable it's fine reporters said it's
all good now a lot of these glitches as
we've talked about across all of the
states as we wrap up fraud week and i'm
getting very near the end of this now um
mikhail kelly garrett is that the name i
don't know how it's pronounced
kelly garrett uh
worked as dominion's project manager
okay because we've talked about dominion
quite a bit sidney powell has said that
there's blatant fraud the fec
chairman said if sydney powell said that
there's evidence i believe her that's
what he said lots of credibility he said
that the day after you said that though
just that way well you know what he's
everyone's borrowing from my notes
that's right you know adventures yo
nothing's you jerks um so uh
mikhail mchale kelly garrett she worked
as dominions project manager he is it a
guy is it a girl kelly
woman
sometimes you guys need to understand i
mispronounce things or i misgender
people
sometimes it's because it's funny that's
true and then sometimes it's because i
read it and i'm reading an article and
there's no picture and i've never
actually heard anyone talking about it
because who's going to talk about this
stuff on the news no one's going to tell
you about corruption talk about this so
this person let's call them let's call
them kelly garrett worked as dominions
project manager then worked at
michigan's democratic party headquarters
and as the deputy director and is now
mayor of lathrop village in michigan
here's something important she uh so it
is a she helped broker a 25 million
dollar contract 25 million dollar
contract between dominion and the state
of michigan while still serving as the
vice chair for the oakland county
democratic party so when people talk
about the swamp when people talk about
getting big money out of politics how
about someone who has 25 million at
stake who's working for that company
while currently sitting in office at the
taxpayer's dime isn't there some kind of
a law against that or is it like insider
trading where it doesn't apply to guys
named newt
i think biden just issued a
pre-executive executive order that said
it was fine oh okay good yeah from the
president-elect's office maybe yes this
is the first time the president-elect is
going to pre-pardon himself yeah yeah
he's a brilliant maneuver it is how it
works out for him cotton he said you
know i always said like donald trump is
playing 4d chess yeah joe biden just
he's playing uh he's playing four he's
playing eight
x
checkers
i'm pardoned that doesn't work that way
ah i was hoping you i was hoping you'd
go along with it no joe
okay someone give me a scratch and sniff
trump is playing chess but bind is
playing hopscotch yes
and i'd like to be playing hungry hungry
hippos if you want to later well that
you could do with frank luntz oh stupid
seinfeld sneakers
no he's playing uh he's playing uh a
jump rope let's hit the rhythm and the
beat let's hit the rhythm of the hat dog
remember that on the sesame street but
tell me they taught me how to play jump
rope and then i did it in canada with a
black accent like the street part of
sesame street and uh i was immediately
beaten up i learned how to do it from a
little show called amen
right when he walks up double dutch amen
to that
does that mean double cheap i don't know
what it means okay uh by the way hit the
notification bell if you are subscribed
on youtube because uh no subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot we broadcast
weekdays 10 a.m eastern and uh of course
the notifications will let you know when
something goes up it's a special like an
election special if we go live uh and
you can always go to livercle.com just
to check these sources that's probably
your best place to stay in touch now
let's go through a recap of the
affidavits okay because this is
important having affidavits by
themselves it's basically a declaration
under oath right you are legally held
liable for that if you make that
declaration uh but we've seen some
corroborating evidence now just like
we've seen some corroborating
corroborating evidence for those uh
electors saying we're not going to
certify this because of irregularities
and now we just showed you why the
irregularities are registered voters 120
registered voters 2 000 and
0.0002 you're like oh
this seems atypical so
the affidavits uh one of the affidavits
this is in michigan it's 20
234 pages
i think that's a lot i don't know this
is on page 23 or something like that but
you guys can go read all of these
affidavits on the website uh that ballot
someone reported that ballots were run
through the machine five times
and uh it seems confirmed by some
internal numbers we brought this from
twitter and uh we verified it where
there have been ballots run one two
three four times that has been done how
many times we don't know where did the
ballots come from came from the pile of
zero
somewhere over there nothing to look in
there it's called magic it's called
magic magic man
there were uh there were ballots not in
the voter database where they just
entered a fake uh birth date of one one
nineteen hundred that's helpful well
it's also helpful because i can say well
see people are trying to say they're
folks 120 years old we just entered in
this birth date as a default date why
would you enter a default date 120 years
old and also why are you entering a
default date at all don't people here
have birth dates weren't they born
in michigan it's usually a wild guess
it's usually a wild guy i like how you
can just identify as 120 year old yeah
it's just like no i want to identify as
a person who was not born i just
appeared i just yeah
a piece of data that would actually make
it legal for you to vote or illegal
we'll just guess yeah it's not really
necessary to get that we've given you an
approximation approximation of when they
were born yeah call it 1900 what makes
you say that
because we have zero data yeah no
registered voters so your guess is as
good as mine how about we don't guess
that'd be crazy where are we gonna get
170 000 votes to win
maybe we shouldn't let them vote yeah
maybe we shouldn't let them vote a
little five-year-old sally has to be
able to vote somehow voter suppression
five-year-olds not voting just sally a
lady named sally voting five times uh
ballots were logged even when they had
no signature or they weren't registered
these are all from the affidavits poll
workers duplicated ballots to incorrect
precincts to run through two ballots for
one person 20 to 30 times
claims that 60 of ballots in one box had
the same signature a city employee
claimed that she was asked to back date
ballots now here's the thing those are
three four five that are from sworn
affidavits that we don't have any
corroborating evidence for but there are
several already that we do now keep in
mind same thing in georgia people said
you would never you'll never find any
difference with a recount you'll never
find any maybe one maybe well actually
found over 5400 new votes the
overwhelming which overwhelming majority
of which were for donald trump and that
wasn't a real recount that was a show
recount
right that was political theater recount
imagine if we had done an actual recount
now right here people refuse to certify
because they don't have access to the
data and uh they were doxxed and
intimidated and some teamsters showed up
with a two by four with a nail through
it and they said okay well certifiable
certify and then they said that they
were intimidated to vote now we see some
of these affidavits are actually being
confirmed like ballots being run several
times do we know
that a city employee has back dated
ballots how do you check this when
you're talking about hundreds of
thousands of votes
from a place with zero registered voters
yeah and you have no record how could
you how could you possibly test to see
if it was a vote a a poll worker a
precinct worker filling in that ballot
or or back dating it or filling in the
signature here's my question bills how
could we possibly audit this at this
point you go back and you count them all
and you but that won't do anything you
look at the ones that have the
information you compare them to the
registered voter rolls which you don't
have sue or not well no no right you
have registered voter rolls and you have
the names on the ballots but what they
didn't do was bother to do anything to
put the information that you would use
to check so for example they're gonna
say
okay let's say the answer was all of
these people who voted they're not
registered voters okay well you know you
can throw them all out right or you
would say oh they but they're not they
are registered voters but we just didn't
check them to make sure how would you
check them how would you have checked
them in the first place it's not like
the ballots come in and they don't have
a name on them so you check the balance
against the existing that's what the
board is saying they're saying these
results don't make any sense right
here's the thing though we have 173 000
votes from no registered voters so what
do you check it against how do you find
if it's an authentic signature if you
don't have them on record well you're
right on that point if they're my my
thing is there's only two ways to go
about it either the ballots are not
registered voters and then there's
nothing to check right they're just off
you throw them or they are registered
voters that the system failed to connect
with an actual registered voter and an
audit would reveal whether or not those
were again either real registered voters
or not real registered voters and the
canvas board is saying guys this is the
only way to check it this is the only
way the thing we cannot certify and they
were bullied but you would have to you
would have to throw out hundreds of
thousands of votes you'd have to throw
out those votes before there's no one
registered voters how would you check
that when you canvas how would you check
to see if a city employee backdated the
ballot seems to me there'd be no way to
do it well some of those things are the
major problems that you would not be
able to so for example when the ballot
comes in and you stamp a certain date on
it you can't tell unless someone you had
a video that showed right what the
ballot was and the person stamping it
and it had the video had a time stamp
you wouldn't be able to know whether it
came in in on time or not on time but
the issue of registered voters is one
where if you have the ballot but the bad
name
the the back date balance you're saying
we need videographic evidence
we need the state government to seize
those red flyer wagons
yes yes hand it over hand it over
share and share a like yeah i don't know
this is the thing is at this point like
you're saying with those god knows how
many of them could have been backdated
this all happened in in
the dead of night and the precinct was
boarded up
you just have to either there's no you
cannot trust this vote in michigan you
either have to do a re-vote you'd have
to toss so many votes and then there are
votes that you can't verify anyway
there's no possible way this is a
quagmire yeah i just don't think that
giggity the michigan the michigan
election
is illegitimate there's no way to trust
it right now and i don't know if there's
any way to certify it because a no one
in the legislature wants to look into
these numbers no one in the media is
asking for these numbers it was shocking
to everyone here i saw you all hanging
with your mouths open like you're in a
disney film and bugs bunny just turned
into a lady bunny and i know that i'm
mixing warner brothers in disney but
shut up star wars nords go watch
mandalorian my point here is
this is something thirsty this is
something
uh
is illegitimate i don't see any solution
to it beyond throwing it out well you
have to take an extraordinary step
because you can't say oh we did this but
then we mixed them all together so you
can never undo it so you just have to
take the vote no you have to take
whatever extraordinary step that is
necessary to say we get to the right
number and by the way it seems like
states are trying to be worse than the
state before like arizona's like oh
we're not done counting it we're the
slowest and george is like holding my
beer we haven't even found all our votes
yet right then you get the mission
arizona's saying hold on hold on don't
rush me
we're taking our time mississippi
detroit
we got 173 000 in four seconds yeah
i mean fly red flag what are you doing
i'm i'm not sure what you mean by
illegitimate vote but i would say that
there is a process by which we can
determine an illegitimate election or i
don't know i don't know what you mean by
a legitimate election but i would say to
the point where you have a number of
processes that was describing up to 30
minutes i think so yeah and more poverty
says i'm not saying i'm right i guess
what i'm saying is i'm not ready to say
that the entire state of michigan and
all of their votes need to be just
discounted because that doesn't make any
sense i think you need to re-vote i
think you need to revoke and have some
and have some actual safeguards in place
you can't have poll workers and you have
zero registered voters 170 000 votes
coming in in the dead of night 97 of
which are for joe biden and no one is
checking it and people are being doxxed
and they're saying the only reason we're
not reset the only reason that we had to
rescind our statement that we weren't
going to certify is because we're afraid
for our families and then you have in
the primaries 800 people who voted who
were dead and they're not even running
this the same way in the primaries and
they're not even fixing it from the
primaries and making it worse i don't
know how you trust it well there's no
re-vote option right there's not an
option to resolve it but
but then you toss the entire state and
you go to every person or the electoral
democrat and you say we're just gonna
ignore it but there is a process that
will reveal the fraud to the extent of
how where these no lack of registered
voters are or are they not registered
and you're right if this is the normal
process the courts will go and say hey
if the way people were taking these in
was back dating them and we have
evidence that shows that they were being
backdated you take that lump of balance
and you take them out my point is you
leave the room there can be no evidence
like you said unless someone was there
someone was there with a nikon going oh
oh they're back dating it so the stuff
that we do have is bad enough where
there's your registered voters they've
been asked no one's answering for it and
then there are things that you can't
prove i mean the electors are the ones
who certify the election i think it has
to go to them that's what happens right
based on fraud and i think this is so
severe in michigan more than any other
state
because again it also just it doesn't
pass the reason test when you look into
how red these counties are and how some
of them switched some of them didn't and
then the county were we were most
curious especially because we wanted to
see how donald trump performed in the
inner city detroit black vote because
the early polls showed that he was up
like 30 something percent had a 48 or 46
approval rating with black voters if
only as a case study to see what would
happen to see how much progress donald
trump has made for black voters in the
republican party we have none of that
and the lies don't even make sense no no
they don't if you look at all the other
data you would have to you would have to
say that these certain precincts and not
even all the precincts just the absentee
votes go against all the data in every
other precinct in every other county and
every other state that committed that
did the elections and throughout history
by the way right throughout history
didn't even know whether it was super
nazi because you didn't even know it
existed right so that was the point
sometimes the most blatant lies are
stupid once you see them but the point
was you were never going to see them
yeah you were never going to know they
were there but then once you see them
you're like oh so obvious now
how many weeks has it been and no one
has pointed this and that's the fault
that's the fault of the obviously the
leftist media they won't there's no
level of fraud well they just assume
that everybody's going to look at it
like that right well there's no level of
fraud because when there was the 128 000
typo in wisconsin this is more severe by
the way and we were messaging that uh
what's his name pete bump whatever it
was something
bump at the washington post he said well
he said well that came in from a biden
county we found it was a typo they
actually added a zero right right but at
that moment in time they just said well
who cares that's normal they weren't
willing to investigate
a hundred thousand blip and what i'm
saying is this is actually more severe
than the typo and no one cares and so
conservatives are at fault too though
the leftist media they know
that you are not going to be doing any
digging that's why you watch them when
you're in an airport
on a layover
but the people on the right and this is
what also bothers me sometimes is they
give you red meat and they want you to
rah-rah yeah voter fraud and i've seen
some people share these videos that are
really bad on the algorithmic voter
fraud uh one of them was from doctor
something and it's this graph and it's
been shared to me 100. and listen it's
actually it's just it's dishonest and
it's using statistics to mislead people
yeah so what you have is the left wing
keeping it completely silent and then
you have people on the right not
actually uh doing the digging and so
here you are this shouldn't be the first
place you're hearing from you should
hear this everywhere you should on every
major am radio show you should hear on
every major conservative podcast you
should be certainly hearing it on fox
news and cnn the fact that we are doing
it we're doing these research did we is
there something going on do we lose a
stream or something we just dropped 10
000 people oh really okay just just
randomly gone all right the algorithm uh
by the way this is a good opportunity as
any to say hey please do follow us uh on
parlor because uh facebook youtube we
never know when uh we never know when
those walls are gonna close in like uh
like uh whatever the first star wars was
i have no idea um is that the garbage
shoot so yes yes so we have to go to
nick depalo on mug club after this but
uh first there's a video making the
rounds
is it what's the company cut cut and
what's the name of the video it's it's
what are white people superior at yeah
is it superior act superior that's
actually the title i believe so yes well
listen
i don't want to start a race war but
titling hmm
um
grammar so here's the thing this i want
to be clear by the way trigger warning
this video is incredibly racist the fact
that it's still allowed on youtube is
mind-boggling to me it's just a bunch of
uh mostly black people and then some
kind of
shape-shifters i don't know
who knows
non-racially bi non-racial binary uh
berating white people no didn't you find
out i think it was harvard recently is
that the asians aren't actually people
of color that's right so yeah you lost
welcome it's a world of privilege it's
really interesting i'm married to
mexican
there's still hope for your children um
so this is on youtube of course and this
was featured there in the youtube page
you know nothing about this and i told
dave because you know he works with i
said like
it's a racist video and uh there are
some third rails because i don't think
that we could respond an exact kind and
let me be clear i don't believe anything
they're saying just like i wouldn't
believe these stereotypes if they were
to be uttered about black people
um but this is the video we are all
going to react to the video
from cut featured on youtube titled what
are white people superior at
what exactly are white people superior
at oh well according to television
everything a white man could fly even a
white woman she could be four foot one
she knew karate she could take down 15
people
okay pause what's the [ __ ] really
quickly what's a folks are there are
there no black superheroes yeah there's
definitely a lot that's what i call
evidence check your sources
white people cannot fly
[Applause]
dc is not it's not a bibliography like
this is
well that's what it was was according to
your imagination
they can fly right according to fake
right and she has something against
short white people according to your
imagination you can vote nine times in
detroit so we all have either i'm five
five i can barely get out of bed from
depression
all right let's keep going just doesn't
get anything no one said whatever
they don't really do
karate they don't really know martial
arts they're called actresses it's
called a movie kind of like how foxy
brown was yeah exactly this is not a new
thing do we have it can you bring all
right let's continue playing
what are white people's superior at
man
are you
huh um is this a white person asking
this
sounds like it
[Music]
letting them get on your countertops
while you're cooking that is a car yes i
get that you love your pet black you
need to take it everywhere like
everywhere i guess you know hey just to
the bathtub you electrocuted
[Applause]
that's black dane cook humor and that
it's something that's totally
unrelatable like listen listen everyone
here knows that white people
always eat [ __ ] tuna
they eat the tuna they walk in they grab
the tuna they put it in their mouth they
can't get enough tuna when they're white
i
white casserole ever ever matter like
never had am
how what's what are blind people
superior nah
watermelon
first off it's like it's not well dave
chappelle maybe people do like certain
foods and i'm sure white people do like
certain foods of course the difference
is white people can be irish they can be
italian right they can be german so they
can like wienerschnitzel they can like
pasta they can like potatoes and haggis
if they're scottish i have no idea we
all have preferences but tuna casserole
is not a white thing no no we're not
superior
[Laughter]
i mean look i'm asian from the waist up
and i love tuna so yeah
you're stupid chicken of the seed is
that [ __ ] chicken or is it tuna i deep
fried it i was like dessert this ain't
no chicken
no chicken
ah tuna oh that's white people food
i'm never gonna eat no muffin i'm gonna
spit it out on the cat on the counter
all right let's keep watching
your dogs why don't you hit it
wait phil's like why don't you eat it it
is just really gerald
he has he's experimented sorry but you
know what i actually do
we may not be better at much but at
least give us not littering
yes
no no white people are terrible at
littering that's why the entire state
motto of texas is don't litter here well
that's why there's not litter though
they listen they're like oh you're right
no
yeah i will say why people are better at
listening
they are better at following
instructions you tell them not to litter
they don't litter you tell [ __ ]
don't burn down walgreens it makes me
kind of want to do it
uh let's
continue of course this is all in good
fun they're the racists it's in a lot of
their recipes making bland food counting
seasoned chicken how are you going to
start whole spice wars and don't even
use seasoning on your food i mean hold
on
pause
the west indian trading first of all bob
evans has a fine flavor
i'm not buying any of this come on guys
i mean for crying out loud think about
uh think about all like hot wings i
don't know if that's a white that was
two guys in buffalo
it's uh what are they talking about i'll
i'll give it to them i would still say
it's a black food
okay i i mean they've appropriated it
they have a pro
the whole beauty of america is you can
be black and eat pasta you don't have to
be an old-time guinea you don't you can
you can eat chicken wings and be white
or you can be black you can eat uh irish
stew and be white or black this is like
you are separating all of us on on
things that a don't even matter and
aren't even true so we're gonna continue
teasing you at the at the level uh which
you actually are a racist but in gentle
prodding let's see more
smelling funky santa claus smelling
[ __ ] comfortable corn mazes white
people are great cocoa butter at having
fun that's a function
of white supremacy because they just
don't have as many stresses
white people that's a fun white people
have fun it's a function of white
supremacy
because they don't have as many stresses
paying taxes i mean listen employing
people not saying that black people
don't pay taxes but there's a
significant portion of white and black
people who don't pay taxes 47 of
americans don't pay federal income tax
did i see the wrong house party
you can tell by the haircut
i am so like i can't
i'm like seeing red hair
yeah well that's why would you see red
you don't have any stresses uh yeah oh
my gosh insane when i first because
i think to be incredible
think about how racist that gentleman in
the mask has to be to have accused every
other person of color of being unable to
or at a severe disadvantage of having
fun right i'm going to tell you right
now trade me spots with kanye just do it
i don't care i'll take all the [ __ ]
about running late to even apply for an
election give it to me i will take it
yeah i will i will even switch and be
beyonce that is fine give that to me
like it's obviously just dog whistles
it's just crazy and also that's one
thing i always said they're like white
people oh you're so lame and uptight you
can't dance like listen i would assume
black people do have more fun i go to a
black night club and it's bouncing you
go to a white club they're line dancing
everyone looks miserable they're just
like kill me
please
i can't deviate from this awful pre-set
of moves that nobody enjoys you go to a
gay night club there's a white shooter
having no fun at all
[Laughter]
too far to be fair no one else was
enjoying themselves yeah
so the but then but then this idea oh
man
why did you give me something to break
over no stressors right yeah okay
especially based on your other
stereotypes white people have no
stressors you say that the next time a
country music festival becomes the worst
mass shooting in american history right
like it was white people and hootie
and an asian girl hey i forget his name
now
darius rucker that's it um he'll always
be hootie to me i wish we had still
forgotten it all right make him cry
let's continue with the rate thanks cut
we do not have the privilege to do
whatever and however we want to what
exactly are white people superior at uh
not getting arrested well i was driving
down the street with uh down the highway
with a friend of mine who was white when
he was like i need to i'm just gonna
pull over and pee and i'm in the
passenger seat and i was like please
don't because a black man thinks
differently if i pull over to the side
of the road and pee a cop is gonna be
right behind me to punish me what
exactly okay pause
insecure
that may or may not be true
but um
first off anyone can be punished for
peeing in the side of the road right i
know someone who was who had to become a
registered sex offender for peeing in a
park at night we thought no one was
there and that's why we you can look
through the archives i think if you just
type in if youtube searches are working
right now which probably not after this
video um if you type in stephencrowderp
instructions i taught people how to pee
while driving on a long road trip the
key is you have to be all the way over
in the white lane and a wide mouth
gatorade bottle in other words it's not
lost on me
that the fuzz
could take me down for public urination
so
you you're just out of touch did you say
the white lane the white land i thought
he said white white lane he's like you
got to be on the white lane because if
you drive in the white lane they don't
get old here's the thing if you're
driving right you got to p here's the
thing you have to be all the way over in
the right lane yeah okay you have to
hold your arm here so no one can see
because if right the passenger side here
if i'm this far it doesn't matter what
i'm doing look you can see it it's like
a dave landau sex tape yeah my strong
preference is as you recall one of the
few rules is that you'd not admit to
crimes on the show while driving is not
a crime yes it is
well allegedly i had a tube
continue i don't want to know where that
was play the video long drive catheters
pretending
being fearful of nothing being ignorant
whoa letting their ego control their
every move privilege briefly killing
victimized playing the victim
congratulating themselves over [ __ ]
that they're incompetent
or that should have already been done
they're superior at being dicks what
exactly okay wow all right
okay look let's take this hey youtube
rachel take this out of context
black people are only superior at being
dicks
now i hope that's taken out of context
so you can now scan 30 seconds in either
direction that is the definition of
racism that's we've gone past
differences like they smell different
listen i think we'll all acknowledge
that you have certain people from
different people from different races
smell different different people from
different areas of the country smell
different different people like
different foods i don't think that's
racism to recognize differences right i
think racism is believing that one race
of people is superior to another solely
because of their race and i think saying
white people all white people in general
are dicks pejorative qualifies you
racist [ __ ] not in general
all white people all are superior at
being dicks and tipping
i mean look
that's a true statement
if if being dicks was a true statement
then maybe it would not be racist but it
is racist because it is not true oh my
gosh of course
there's seven maybe eight percent of the
white population there's not dicks and
that's true i mean none of them are here
but yeah right yeah no i know at least
two or three white friends that i have
that aren't dicks yeah this room would
not be a good sample yeah no i look and
i know white people that you know
they'll they'll tip you know maybe 12
percent yeah his name is bernie sanders
yeah all right let's go yeah
the key is to round down right
lack of empathy intellectualizing
oppression did i say oppression they're
just creatively thinking this is
hardcore like always staying one step
ahead of other people we get rid of
slave catchers and let's just expand the
police force like that stuff to me is
wild what exactly are what can we pause
no you're gonna you guys are pulling a
prank on me this is all one big
glorified ad for spirit halloween
costume it's gotta be right yeah
we got predator we've got mid-century
farmer in all sizes look we got we got
up we got
take a guess
i mean we got girl from the craft but
you mean the one from like american
history actually really gummy and [ __ ]
yeah look yeah
look at this we paid that big scale this
collar will fit a whale
also something you privileged you get to
where you wailing i never been wailing
you want a pharrell almost sombrero hat
[Music]
sorry
this is the worst fish oh my gosh
i
was wondering if this was real this is
absolutely real it's kind of 100 real is
it really yeah and they're all in
biden's cabinet real let's continue
watching
i believe that
we don't matter
superior feeling superior thinking
they're superior thinking that they're
supposed to thinking that they are like
if someone called all blacks
how about claiming that you know they
are actually a whole separate race when
actually white dna comes from
the black female then what are we
arguing about can we pause honey
how many people here do we think voted
for biden a white man hmm
97 they were voting kamala i bet you you
find more votes for donald trump in this
cast
than in wayne county yeah
enough at four a.m but how many more
registered voters probably yeah
take the number of the cast and then
subtract zero i mean just
we know for a fact that this violates
every social media platform's stated
guidelines oh yeah remember how we were
looking as you know not that we have
been archiving this
this is one to save uh yeah there's a
thousand of them yeah we have a lot of
but i don't think anyone has been this
is this one
shut up shut up your chinese piece of
[ __ ] yes
seriously just imagine that like people
get mad because i go i thought youtube
was going to crash through the ceiling
like superman and like you demonetized
you
it's like we talk about people get mad
they say it's offensive it's funny
we've had these conversations with some
random people you know at some point who
may or may not and they're like um
do you constantly have to refer to your
lawyer as half asian that scene though
it's like
that's the point right but that is
considered more offensive than like all
what is it just all white people are
dicks well i come from a black woman
yes we all do we all do oh i do think it
is because you're a crack people
incredibly incredibly ironic to say
there's no race
but you came from this race right yeah
it's like wait i just thought we'd just
doing just literally a half sentence
earlier you said there's no race so race
is a figment of your imagination oh i
guess if you wanna and [ __ ] you white
boy
i'm confused
it's like that old test when you look at
the dress do you see a yellow a gold
dress or a black dress these people just
want to burn it
yes
and by these people i mean these people
in this video who are racist i mean this
clan rally
i wonder how goated they are too by the
white person with their guilt that put
this video together and edited it yeah
because that's what it feels like did
any of them feel oppressed that it was a
white person that asked them to do this
i don't know a white person behind the
camera that it's a white person that
owns this company i don't think we have
the full video but at the end of it
actually you hear a kind of like talk
super hero slow clap from the producer
and it's just david duke yes
all right let's keep watching how long
how much longer is it another oh we got
about a minute two minutes okay a minute
two minutes oh few minutes all right
let's get into this what kind of lies uh
the lies of history they say that
history by nobody
but
the victor could be replaced by the
colonizer what are white people superior
at conquering imperialism
to open up
i thought it was king hippo yes and
everybody else really they ballsy they
rolls up all over the world and they
walk into everybody's house and says oh
this is nice i'm going to take your [ __ ]
and they have no qualms about it yeah
yeah yeah hold on a second
it's a bunch of white people who
committed two billion dollars in damage
right now with these black lives matter
riots i mean there were a lot of white
antifa people there were some white
people but it was black lives matter
riots
so if you're gonna blame us for all the
evils of white people
does the label black lives matter take
responsibility for the crimes committed
at the black lives matter rallies even
though there were some white people
there
i really see a powdered wig during a
home invasion
i'd love to blame the settlers it's like
they're it's like it's like they're all
of their references for white people
like old cagney films well they said ah
listen see i'm gonna take your stuff
sonny don't call the copper see they
won't trust you because you're negro
right
well they said they got rid of slave
catchers and brought in the police i'm
like i think i don't know if we're
thinking the same thing here yeah well
that's their argument is the police is
the modern day slave force uh but
where's the most highest levels of
police brutality where the highest
levels of black
crimes and jailing for crimes and
arrests they're in democratic controlled
cities that have for a large part being
controlled by uh minorities both as
chief of police mayors city council
don't give me some of the fact check you
know that the average is skewed by
kamala harris she put in more black
that's true she's like rudy giuliani in
reducing crime she put in so many
non-violent black offenders behind bars
that it skews the numbers well it's not
fair hey that was the pass and the
president now she is no longer in charge
of oh yeah i don't know but she wears
chuck taylor's
my vote let's continue with this yeah
listen to tupac in 1985
let's hear it right
is it freezing out now
no no no no no that's a horrible taste
there we go we can't bring up our white
privilege boy sketch right now that
might be accused of soft racism as
opposed to just like our core racism
just play it just let's just skip to the
last minute
like stealing people's lives just
because they feel like it you are white
whoa you know this you're pretty white
you say sir and you're a killer too you
are adopted like a photo negative of a
microphone that says it's okay to do
this and part of that philosophy allows
you to be ignorant right and they're
like oh i didn't know what exactly are
white people superior at taking what's
not there taking [ __ ] taking our ideas
copycat ginger for
a second
uh
can someone can
[Laughter]
i don't think we're very it's not one of
our skill sets but look the point isn't
that there's a certain race that that is
actually predisposed by their genetics
to do certain things it's that bad
people exist in all races right and
that's the whole point and the problem
is that unfortunately in the black
community right now they're encouraged
by this kind of hateful rhetoric and
this is the kind of hateful rhetoric
when you say white people are dicks they
still commit genocide and they want to
enslave black people that's how you
justify violence against white people
just like that's how you justify
violence against trump supporters by
calling them nazis this right here
justifies black violence black on white
violence which to me is a horrible thing
so is white on black violence so is
black on black violence but this right
here justifies it because you talk about
white people
on a level that is sub-human and that is
what leads to the verifiable crime
statistics
it also shows their own insecurity and
that's the problem is this this
brutalizes both groups
this is something to mess up both sides
because it is designed to make us angry
and it is designed to make them feel
like they are less important in our
society all right okay let's continue
watching this and then i have a quick
trip story from this morning
i don't know if i can tell things that
do not belong to them
other people's cultures and making you
believe that they invented it maybe
they're thinking of it as repurposing
it's like recycle and repurpose as my
grandma was saying then white folk
they'll take it if you don't copyright
it they are very good at destruction
of humanness
what exactly are white people superior
at white people
uh with anything nothing nothing nothing
there is nothing nothing i don't believe
that they're superior in any way shape
or form i love her skin color is
different
i don't know i would say listen i
wouldn't and i certainly wouldn't make
that that's enough superiority that's
the generalization i certainly wouldn't
make the argument that they're superior
at editing or doing end cards because
that sounded like a white person asking
the questions uh but i certainly
wouldn't argue that white people are
incompetent at everything nor would i
argue that with black people i cannot
believe that that is allowed to stay out
and actually got some jews from uh big
companies at the with the big tech
overlords yeah i would love to see a
video where it's just white people
saying the exact same things right why
don't we put it out there yeah
i think maybe what are the faces maybe
to keep people from getting killed right
you know put it out there and then it's
going to be about what
yeah can you imagine the reaction that
you would they like to show their pets
the world
they've never seen a black person out of
their homes right forever dog fighting
[Laughter]
wait taking my
furniture right
i don't know if is nick the power still
going to be on after cause i know he
probably is mad that we have him late
okay okay so sorry nick we're going to
be going so let me tell you a quick
story here missed that last this
yeah he did this happened um this
morning
i was at a you know well here actually
really quick we'll end on this i was at
quick trip as you well know
[Music]
and people want to say that america is
divided and quick trip not a sponsor but
you should be because i will not set
foot in the turkish prison that is
racetrack
as you should not so i was at a quick
trip this morning uh i had to go pick up
some half and half for the missus and um
so i go in and the rule the sign says
you have to wear a mask right so
everyone's wearing a mask i'm like okay
put it on just because i don't want to
cause a scene right and this black guy
walks right past me and he's not wearing
a mask and he walks right in and this is
this was the exact conversation i said
ah man not wearing a message good good
for you that's ballsy and he goes man
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
is this [ __ ] i said no no and i tore off
my mask symbolically i said no no listen
i'm saying that's a ballsy move i
appreciate that you walked in you did
your thing and he goes man it's too
[ __ ] early i'm telling you i'm
telling you i'm telling you you know
they repeat i'm telling you i said hey
hey hey it's a compliment take the win
and he mumbled and he walked out and
realized this is where we are in this
country for some reason people are so
uptight hey you have the covid you have
the tension you have the mask and then
you have this racial tension because for
some probably because people are
watching videos like cut they think that
if a white person offers them a
compliment that somehow it's some kind
of an insult yeah if i said that i was
lit i was very clear in complimenting
him after that i purchased my half and
half i walked out and there were some
police officers nearby and i have told
you i go by and i always thank police
officers and i said hey i just want to
thank you for your service and they
always go well man you know thank you
people don't do that nowadays and then i
noticed the black guy was in his card
and he popped his head out and i
thought he didn't wear a mask
and then i felt i felt racist because i
thought i was racist
and i said to the cops i said you know i
said i really appreciate you guys
actually like first i know you're not
like grade school teachers or anything
but you know being shot at it in record
numbers i consider you first responders
they said thanks man we don't get a lot
of thank you so do uh do make sure that
you don't tell someone hey good for you
uh uh for doing whatever you're doing
just like in other words if this is the
lesson people are of different races
just don't talk to each other no just
listen to cut listen to kamala harris
and just learn that we should be more
divided than ever that's the message to
take away from president biden elect and
this is something sometimes people say
why are you so positive why are when the
country is going to crap with the
election right this has happened we had
the election stream look this is not me
putting up appearances
i um i really do think that the country
tends to be a better place today than it
was yesterday and tomorrow than today i
tend to believe that in the long run the
united states and i know that won't last
forever but
you kind of look at you know the
pendulum swings both ways right and the
pendulum swung from barack obama uh so
i'm doing your left here to donald trump
really hard as hard as you possibly
could right you went from barack obama
far left to donald trump not necessarily
far right but perceived that way and
that was a harder swing than from george
w bush center right to barack obama and
now we've gone to biden which i would
say is not as hard of a swing
as george bush was to uh was to barack
obama and when people say what is your
hope for the country here's what i will
say when i first got my concealed carry
license okay this was in texas and i
used to be able to do it where you could
do it in someone's house as long as
there was a certified certification and
this was right before barack obama was
becoming president and the guy asked me
because at this point i was on fox news
he said well
what do you think is going to happen
with our country i said you know i i i'm
optimistic cautiously i think that
barack obama's probably going to do some
damage with policies but i think we have
systems in place that can uh that can
rectify that and he said
i think in two months people be shooting
each other in the street for a loaf of
bread so whenever someone says the
country's going away and it's done i
picture that guy and how crazy and wrong
he was and you know his predictions are
about the same chance of getting it
right as dick morris so chin up things
aren't that bad there's always a silver
lining and this is the united states of
america don't be defeatist because then
you just allow yourself to be defeated
right now actually we do have to hit
like if you're watching this hit like
right now because it helps this video
get out to everybody especially with the
voter fraud segment but uh for everyone
else right now we are going to go
exclusively to mug club we have nick
depaolo and your chat youtube you
what is there something i said piss off
youtube